which one was the good brother well no
come on David coming back in the train
and we got some beer we're using too
much force we need to change these drug
laws voted for Jennifer and were you
shocked by the level of the tree all
leveled against you and your family I'm
kind of like Martin Luther when he was
on trial and he said here I stand I can
do no other but aren't you still getting
caught up in the still site in the in
the same cycle of buying influence no no
well so far we we're lot of 68 yrs at it
as you can tell so you saw it a couple
of weeks back saying something like 150
families and contributed overwhelmingly
yeah that's not a way to run a democracy
say to me it depends on folk to what end
government's picking winners and losers
and you want to be a winner more than
you do a loser so you give to slant it
your way what would you say to your
critics I would say you're just like any
other crony capitalist I expect
something in return I would love to have
the government stop this corporate
welfare
you
the 2016 presidential election is the
most expensive yet these candidates are
getting most of their money from super
PACs which are independent